على مدار الساعه ومنذ ان ضرب الزلزال
مدينه كهرمان مرش لم يتوقف العمل
يجهز موظفوا الهلال الاحمر التركي 500
خيمه يوميا
ويدور الحديث هنا عن الحاجه لانتاج الضعف
في هذا العدد لتامين اقامه الاف شردهم
الزلزال
نعمل بالتنسيق مع اداره الطوارئ افاد
لتصنيع الخيام وارسالها للمحافظات
المتضرره وتوزيعها وتركيبها كل خيمه
بمساحه 16 مترا مربعا وتتسع لعائله واحده
لا يمكن للخيام ان تكون حلا طويل الامد
هذا ما جعل صناعه البيوت الجاهزه تنتعش
اليوم هذه الشركه مثلا تنقل للمناطق
المنكوبه 50 وحده سكنيه يوميا منذ وقع
الزلزال وتتحدث عن مضاعفه طاقه المصانع
لزياده انتاجها
مواصفات هذه المنازل تتيح العيش فيها
لفتره اطول لذا تطلبها افات لنقل
المنكوبين اليها وهناك مدنيون اما من
المتضررين او المتبرعين باتوا يطلبونها
بشكل شخصي ايضا
اكثر من 300 الف خيمه ارسلتها افاد
ومنظمات دوليه نصب منها حتى الان 170 الفا
ويفضل كثيرون اليوم الحصول على منزل مؤقت
في انتظار اعاده الاعمار ان كان الايواء
مشكله في ظل تزايد اعداد من يتم اجلؤهم او
من يغادرون المناطق المنكوبه فالاعمار
معضله كبرى تتطلب وقتا وتواجه الكثير من
التحديات فرح زمن شوقي الجزيره انقره